Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome back to our Operative Dentistry series.
In this video, we'll cover everything from hand instruments to hand pieces and burs used
in Operative Dentistry.
So put on your seat belts and let's get to it.
So the two main categories of dental hand instruments are non-cutting and cutting instruments.
This is certainly not a list of every dental instrument out there, but the ones that are
most commonly used, and that'll come up on the board exam.
In the second half of the video, we'll talk about hand pieces, which fall into their
own category.
So dental hand instruments have three main regions.
The handle, which is represented here by the letter C, is usually about 6 mm in diameter.
It can be eight-sided, like the one shown here, or it can be round, and sometimes it
has a ribbed grip, like you see here, or it can be smooth and flat.
The shank is represented here by the letter B, and the shank may have one or more bends
in it.
You see one bend right here, and then another right here.
And that allows the working end, which we'll talk about in a second, to be aligned with
the long axis of the handle.
And so the working end is represented by the letter A, and it should lie along the long
axis of the instrument for the best balance and control.
So you can see and appreciate how that lines up pretty well with the long axis of the rest
of the instrument there.
And the working end either consists of a blade and a cutting edge, or a nib and a face.
So the blade and cutting edge refers to terms for a cutting instrument, nib and face for
a non-cutting instrument.
So if we look at these diagrams up here, the nib refers to the entire hook part of this
dental explorer, which is a non-cutting instrument.
The face refers to the little point or the explorer time at the very end of the instrument.
That's the part that's contacting the tooth or the restorative material.
For cutting instruments, we have different terminology.
The blade is the actual cutting part of the instrument, so that's this entire portion
right here, and even more specifically, the cutting edge is the tiny little edge, the
specific sharp part that contacts the tooth or the restorative material.
So the handle is what you hold, the shank is for transition, and the working end is what
actually does the work.
So now we can talk about some specific non-cutting dental hand instruments.
The first we'll talk about the dental mirror, the small angled mirror, allows you to see
areas of the mouth that otherwise be difficult or impossible to see.
For example, the occlusal surfaces of the upper molars, or lingual surfaces of the upper incisors,
would require you to have the patient sitting way back, and you likely have to twist your
neck somehow to get a clear view, but the mirror makes this a lot easier.
We call this ability to look at oral structures using the mirror in direct vision, as opposed
to direct vision, where your eyes can look at the tooth or structure of interest directly.
The dental explorer provides tactile sensitivity to detect if margins of restorations have
good integrity with the surrounding tooth structure, if the margins of crowns fit well
to the tooth, and there are many other uses, historically they've been used to detect
caries, but doing so to roughly can actually transition an incipient lesion to a cavitated
lesion, like we talked about in the previous two videos.
So we have different variations of the explorer, the shepherd's hook, maybe the most commonly
used, also called a number 23 explorer, this is the classic curved end, again, most commonly
used today.
The back action explorer, or the number 17, is this flatter shorter hook, which is great
for detecting interproximal areas, if you're detecting margins of restorations between
teeth, and also for detecting sub-gingival calculus.
Lastly, there is the number 2 or pigtail explorer, which curves under and around, and can be
preferred by some providers for detecting crown and restoration margins.
Again, there are more out there, but these are among the most common and commonly tested.
The peridontal probe is used to routinely measure pocket depths, and they can be used
to measure other things like the width of teeth, the amount of overbite of a patient,
etc.
There are different versions of this as well, the UNC-15 probe measures up to 15 millimeters.
Each mark here, it's kind of small to see, but each mark represents 1 millimeter, and
the bigger hash marks here represent 4-5 millimeters, 9-10, and the final increment 14-15.
The Williams probe has little marks at 1-2-3, it skips 4, goes to 5, skips 6, and then 7-8-9-10,
and the marquee probe shows 3-millimeter increments, 0-3 is this first silver part, then 3-6 is
this thick hash, 6-9-9-12, etc.
The amalgam condenser is used to condense amalgam into the depths and corners of a cavity preparation
to ensure that there are no voids in the material.
It can be also used for condensing composite in much the same way.
Remember, we're still talking about non-cutting instruments here, so this part, the working
end of this instrument is going to be called the nib, and it's the portion of the condensing
instrument that does the work, and the face is the actual end of the instrument that comes
into contact with the restorative material being condensed.
This part is usually smooth, but it can also be serrated.
The ball burnisher is one of my personal favorites, it typically has two ends, a small, round
end, and a larger football-shaped end, and it's really great for burnishing and even
carving the surface of an amalgam restoration before it completely sets to give it some
contour and anatomy, or it can be used in a similar way to smooth out the occlusal surface
of a composite restoration before it's cured.
All right, so that's a brief overview of some of the most common non-cutting instruments.
Let's talk about some cutting dental hand instruments this time, and we'll look at most
of the, in fact, we'll look at all of the instruments listed here on this slide.
It's a bit of an overgeneralization here, but this is generally what each of these categories
of instruments applies to and works on, and I find it as a helpful memory tool for the
board exam, just to keep this in the back of your head.
So scalars are typically working to remove calculus from teeth, excavators are typically
used on removing carious dentin, or at least working on dentin to structure, chisels for
removing unsupported and/or friable enamel, and the other category, typically these are
going to be used for modifying the restoration of some sort, others basically a category I
threw together of a couple instruments that we'll mention at the end of this section of
the video.
All right, we can now introduce a formula that describes the dimensions of the working
end of most cutting instruments.
I see this come up on the board exams quite frequently, so let's spend some time unpacking
and really understanding this concept.
So the formula consists of four numbers.
The first number corresponds to the width of the blade in tenths of a millimeter.
So a number 10, a number of 10 means that the blade is one millimeter wide.
So if we're looking at the width of the blade, we're talking about this dimension right in
here.
So again, a number of 10 for this number refers to one millimeter width of the blade, which
is quite common, and also is the case for the instrument pictured here.
So we'll write 10 down here for the first number.
The second number refers to the angle of the cutting edge to the long axis of the blade.
So this one is a little bit more involved, the cutting edge is here, the actual part that's
contacting the tooth or restorative material.
And the long axis of the blade runs up here.
I apologize for it, not a perfect straight line there, but you can see what I'm going
for there.
So the angle between these two lines is a perfect 90 degrees in this case.
So for this, we would just write 90 for our second number.
That's the angle between the blade and the cutting edge.
But if and only if this is 90 degrees, we can actually omit the second number from the
formula.
And that's because 90 is the most common.
Most of these instruments are going to have a blade that is perpendicular to its cutting
edge.
So we can omit that number and we just assume that that angle is 90 degrees.
Otherwise we have to list what that angle is.
All right, let's move to the third number.
This simply corresponds to the length of the blade.
So that's going to be this dimension right in here.
And so it's simply listing the length of the blade in millimeters.
So this one's nice and easy.
The blade happens to be seven millimeters long.
So the third number, we just write seven.
And finally, the fourth number, we get a little bit more complicated again.
And the fourth number corresponds to the angle of the blade relative to the long axis of
the handle.
So remember the second number was the angle of the cutting edge to the long axis of the
blade.
Now this is the angle of the blade to the long axis of the handle or the entire instrument.
So because there's a lot more variation in this number, it can literally be anywhere between
zero and 360 degrees.
So this one is reported not as an angle, but as a percentage of 360 degrees.
So if this number were 10, let's say, that would signify 10% of 360 degrees, which means
the blade would be 36 degrees off axis.
This instrument's fourth number happens to be 14, which would correspond to 14% of 360
degrees, which is about 50 degrees.
So the angle that this blade takes relative to the long axis of the handle, which runs
this way, this angle right in here happens to be 50 degrees.
So we don't write 50, we write 14, which represents 14% of 360 degrees.
So if you can remember what each of these numbers just kind of generally represents,
that will be enormously helpful on the board exam.
And the idea behind all of this is that if you know the formula of a cutting instrument,
you can visualize and identify what kind of hand instrument it's describing.
And the board exam will sometimes even refer to the specific formulas.
So I'll include them in the slides for each of the following instruments we discuss.
But if you've got nothing else out of this slide, just remember the kind of this part
of the descriptions, and that will be enough to net you at least one or two questions when
they ask about what a specific number of the formula refers to.
And here's just another way of looking at it, we just broke this down a bit more simply.
So let's start with the dental scalars and we'll actually start with an exception.
The scalars that are used to remove calculus are one of the few cutting instruments that
don't have that four digit formula.
In fact, they follow a different numbering system entirely that we discuss more in depth
in the periodontic series if you're interested in that.
So scalars usually are two-sided and each working end has two cutting edges to it.
And they adapt closely to the two surface and remove calculus from the crown or the
root surface.
There are universal types that can be used anywhere in the mouth and then specific types
like Gracie instruments that are designed for specific teeth and areas in the mouth.
On here we have another categorization.
Sickle scalars are scalars that have sharp points at the end of their blades.
And they are used for calculus above the gum line or super-gingival calculus so that you
don't accidentally shred the gum tissue if you drive that sharp point subgingibly.
Turettes on the other hand, not pictured here, have rounded edges and are used for calculus
below the gum line because you have less risk of damaging the soft tissue.
Spoon excavators are used for gentle and controlled carries removal.
Their formula is 11.5/7/14 and now you know what all that is talking about.
The second number is omitted because the cutting edge is perpendicular to the blade as it is
in most instruments.
Some operators like using small controlled movements with the spoon excavator to scrape
carious dentin with the spoon shaped paddles of this excavator.
And this is most useful for very soft, infected dentin removal.
The black spoon is just a larger, more robust version of the spoon excavator.
It can be also used to burnish metal like a Tafelmeyer matrix band or the margin of a
gold crown with the rounded back of this black spoon working end.
You can notice how this first number is larger, 15 referring to the blade width being 1.5mm
as opposed to a little bit less in the spoon excavator.
The enamel hatchet is a double ended cutting instrument used for planing walls of enamel.
And the bevel on one end of the instrument planes the facial wall and the bevel on the
other end of the instrument planes the lingual wall.
Here's a close up view of what that process might look like in part of the cavity preparation
process.
The bin angle chisel is also a double ended cutting instrument used for planing walls
of enamel.
It's called bin angle because there are two angles in the shank.
We can locate one here and one here and that's to allow for the proper orientation of the
blade for optimal control and balance when using this instrument.
It's similar to the enamel hatchet and function but this blade happens to be perpendicular
to the blade of the enamel hatchet.
So it enables use in the other side of the mouth or in areas that an enamel hatchet simply
cannot access.
So if we compare this directly with the enamel hatchet you can see how this blade you can
kind of see the face of that blade whereas this one is parallel to the screen or perpendicular
to the screen I should say so that you can notice that those two blades are perpendicular
to each other.
The gingival margin trimmer is similar to the enamel hatchet except this instrument is designed
for planing enamel at the gingival floor of a preparation rather than the facial and
lingual walls like the two instruments we just talked about.
And don't worry we'll talk much more about the anatomy of a cavity preparation including
the external and internal walls in the next video in the series.
So the cutting edge of this instrument is most importantly not perpendicular to the long
axis of the blade.
So this is one of the times when there will be a second number in this four digit formula
for the distinct two versions of this gingival marginal trimmer.
So the distal margin trimmer has a number, a second number that's greater than 90 which
is for a gingival floor on the distal side of a tooth.
The mesial gingival margin trimmer has a number less than 90 which is for the gingival floor
on the mesial side of a tooth.
So just remember for the distal you're going to see a number greater than 90 for the mesial
version of this instrument you're going to see a second number less than 90.
The main difference and benefit of the gingival margin trimmer over the enamel hatchet is
that angle of the cutting edge which allows for you to properly bevel the gingival floor.
And again we can talk about more of that in the rest of the series.
So you can appreciate how this enamel hatchet again that cutting edge is perpendicular to
the long axis of the blade whereas that is not the case if we were to follow that long
axis of the blade this cutting edge is not perpendicular and nor is this one and this
is showing the two different variations of this instrument depending on which side of
the tooth you're working on.
Alright next we have the discord cleoid carver which is yet another double ended instrument
it typically has a rounded handle and it's used for a carving and contouring amalgam.
The cleoid end refers to the claw like end for carving grooves into the amalgam and the
discord end is the circular disc like end for carving pits and fossa in the amalgam.
The Holland back carver is a double ended round handle instrument used for placing, carving
and contouring amalgam.
The two ends on either side of the instrument are oriented 90 degrees to one another.
Alright so that's enough about hand instruments let's talk about how to hold them.
So a normal pin grasp involves holding a dental instrument with your index finger and your
thumb and the instrument would rest on the middle finger supporting it.
Your ring finger is used as a finger rest on a nearby steady surface to keep this hand
stabilized.
However the board examiners and most dental providers today prefer the modified pin grasp
which adds the middle finger to grabbing the instrument and so the instrument would then
rest on the ring finger behind it.
This provides additional control for fine motor function and then you use both your
ring finger and your pinky finger together for a stable finger rest.
A firm finger rest is necessary for stabilization of your hand so in a case the patient moves
it around you essentially move with them because those fingers are directly and stably supported
on one of their oral structures so you can rest on adjacent teeth or the maxilla which
are the most stable structures.
The mandible is stable if the patient is biting on a bite block but otherwise they can freely
open their clothes and again you will move with them if that's the case.
Also maintaining a short working radius is important and that means that you grab the
instrument more towards the working end so that your fulcrum is nearer to the working
end for more control and more accuracy.
Alright let's talk about rotary instruments now.
So we have the low speed or slow speed handpiece which operates at less than 12,000 RPMs.
RPMs are revolutions per minute and even though it's the slowest of these handpiece
varieties 12,000 RPM is still pretty quick that's 200 spins per second and so it can
easily injure yourself or the patient if you're not careful.
The low speed handpiece is used for cleaning and polishing teeth with a trophy cup for
finishing and polishing a restoration with a polishing cup or brush and perhaps most important
for the board exam for carries excavation. The board examiners love to ask about this
that a large round burr in a slow speed handpiece is the best way to carefully remove a affected
dentin near the pulp.
Here is the slow speed motor.
This is the latch type contraingal slow speed attachment for carries excavation and polishing
and this here is the straight attachment for the trophy cup for hygiene cleanings.
The high speed handpiece is used for tooth preparation whether that be for carries removal,
for crowns, removing old restorations and many other procedures that require quote unquote
drilling teeth. They usually have a fiber optic light and an air water spray built into
the unit.
The medium speed handpiece is not routinely used but it can be used for the same applications
as the high speed though not quite as efficient and notice how the high speed operates at greater
than 200,000 RPM so you can imagine how quick that burr that is going to be inside that
handpiece is going to be rotating. The medium speed operates between these two thresholds
for low and high speed.
The restat is this foot pedal that is used to control all of these handpiece varieties
often with variable speed depending on how hard you push down on this foot pedal.
The switch right here turns the water on and off when you are using a high speed handpiece.
So burrs that you load into the handpieces have their own anatomy of course more terminology
but there is an overlapping term with hand instruments that can be kind of confusing.
So let's break this down real quick. A burr consists of a shank which does not serve the
same purpose as the shank for hand instruments.
So the shank here is the part of the burr that is inserted into the head of the handpiece
so that's the part that is going inside this area of the handpiece.
The neck is the part which transitions to the head which is the actual cutting part of the
instrument that does the work. The first of these is a high speed burr, the second of
these is a latch type slow speed burr.
So burrs were created and we had two main categories of these diamond burrs historically
called diamond instruments and not burrs but we are going to call them and collapse them
into the greater category of burrs because that's what the ADA and manufacturers have
done.
So let's talk about the carbide burrs first. They are made of tungsten carbide and this
is what they look like. They come in a variety of sizes and shapes and because of their material
and design they are better for end cutting. So they are better for cutting at their ends
like for punch cuts to start a preparation. They also create a smooth preparation wall,
they are good for amalgam removal and for creating retentive features. They also tend
to produce less heat.
The diamond burrs on the other hand are better for side cutting although you can use either
of these for end in side cutting of course but if we are being technical and talking
about things that the board examiners like to ask they are better for side cutting and
are therefore preferable for preparations, bevels and enameloplasty due to the greater
hardness of diamond and the more effective cutting overall but as a downside it generates
more heat and they are way more expensive.
Interestingly for carbide burrs the amount of blades corresponds to its function so if
we start with 6 blades that is a typical cutting burr but if we go up to 12 blades that is
a finishing burr so it is going to cut less but it is going to cut smoother so it is great
for finishing a restoration getting towards that polishing final state.
If we add even more blades to the mix we are getting into fine and ultra fine finishing
burrs so you can think of it like this, the more blades that you have the less too structure
each of those blades is going to be digging in so more blades means a smoother cut and
less blades is more aggressive and more cutting efficient.
For diamonds similar policy but the finer the grit of the diamond the less aggressive
the burr will be the coarser the grit of the diamond the more aggressive it will be.
So let's talk about some specific burrs commonly tested on the board exam and I mean these
come up all the time.
The 245 burr pictured here on the left is 3mm long and 0.8mm in diameter.
I wish I had some kind of memory trick for you but I promise you memorize this if you
can it will certainly show up on test day so 3mm long this part here 0.8mm in diameter.
It's described as being pear shaped or inverted cone sometimes it's called an inverted cone
design and it has these rounded corners along the bottom and it sort of tapers up towards
the neck of the instrument.
The 330 burr pictured on the right is half the length of the 245 so it's only 1.5mm long
but it's the same diameter it's sort of an optical illusion here but this is actually
the same diameter it's still 0.8mm in diameter and it's the same shape pear shaped or inverted
cone.
The smaller size is helpful for pediatric preparations so it's often a go to for your
primary tooth cavity preps and lastly we have the 169 elber another commonly chosen one
this is a tapered fissured design it tapers down this way as you go towards the neck of
the instrument and it's preferred for this thin tip of the burr that's used for creating
retentive features secondary retentive features and we can talk more about slot design and
the next video.
So 245 330 most commonly tested 169 el sometimes gets tested for its unique shape.
And lastly some hazards that we need to talk about for these rotary instruments I mentioned
even the slow speeds are operating at relatively quick speeds and so you can easily damage
tissue if you're not careful so some things to keep in mind the pulp is at risk due to
the vibration caused by the instrument heat generated particularly from diamond instruments
and desiccation so it's always important if you're operating at high speeds you're generating
a lot of heat we want to rely on that air and water spray from the handpiece and also
making sure that everything is well isolated so that we don't slip and damage soft tissue
the lips the tongue and the cheek are all examples of nearby soft tissue.
So using cotton roll isolation rubber dam isolation using firm finger rests operating
with your fulcrum near to the working end of a hand instrument all of those are great
practices to eliminate potential hazards.
So we have to protect our eyes we use glasses with side shields protect our ears we have
potential hearing loss which depends on the intensity of the loudness the frequency of
the sound the duration of the noise and the susceptibility of the individual these handpieces
can get quite loud and if you're using them all through the day Monday to Friday you're
going to be experiencing quite a lot of duration of noise so that's something to keep in mind
as well and of course inhalation risk you know these things I'm sure we're going to
get some changes in our PPE after this coronavirus pandemic but as far as the board exam is concerned
for now things they like to know for you to know about is that the rubber dam protects
the patient from inhalation and masks protect the personnel including the doctor and the
staff alright so that's it for this video on instrumentation I know it was a lot of stuff
to cover but hopefully you found it helpful and enjoyed listening so thank you so much
for watching guys please like this video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to this channel
for much more on operative and all things dentistry if you're interested in supporting this channel
and what I do please check out my patreon page thank you to Michael Raja, Rabbi Boyd,
Rhea Wadwa, Jonathan Muff, David Jayden, Isabella Kaldis, Ali Benstier, Berea Hefnawi and all
of my patrons out there for their support you can unlock extra content like access to
my video slides if you want to take notes on them and additional practice questions and
explanations for the board exam so go check that out the link is in the description below
thanks again for watching everyone I'll see you in the next video